you okay your leg shake is rattling the
windows out there i'm stressed it's
captain holt you won't believe what he
said to me hello santiago how's your
lunch
pretty bad right
do you know why i engaged in small talk
with you earlier because small talk is
for strangers and con men and that's
what i am to you now stranger no i
i did it because
i am a con man
i was trying to con you into believing
everything is normal with me when
it is not
kevin and i am separated
oh my god
why
it's been a tough year to be a black man
and a police captain
and a human
i've been pushed to the brink
emotionally and physically i went into
survival mode and it seems i have
neglected my personal life
does anyone else know not here
i have successfully hidden it for months
not very well i might add i made small
talk with peralta on five separate
occasions and he never even batted an
eye he just blathered on about someone
named uh
wario yeah he does that but you
[Laughter]
you
noticed that something was off with me
the very first day you returned
that just shows how well you know me
and while i'm not yet ready to talk
about it it's uh nice
feeling like i'm not alone
anymore
and that's thanks to you
raymie
just so you know i am not raymie
we are rainy just be glad i said it
totally yes i am thank you sir we got
off to a bad start there with the bees
and kevin rolling down the hill and then
of course the second swarm of bees but
we're good now right
can you guys hear me
you keep moving away from me for some
reason
i wish a bee would sting me in both ears
right now so they'd still shut as well
what was that i couldn't hear you i'll
just assume you said keep going anyways
yeah i just figured if i could get you
guys together i could create a magical
moment but of course we now know that
magic doesn't exist
it's a corn creek oh i can't believe it
i finally spot a corn creek and my eyes
are swollen shut it's okay kevin i'll
describe it to you okay have you ever
seen a duck peralta i got this
the beak color is pantone 4685c
the wing is pantone 2322c spotted with
4515c
the tail is pantone 7525c
with bands of 419c oh my oh kevin the
throat pantone 75-28c
oh raymond
those are some hot pantones
they were being so sweet with each other
and holding hands it was amazing they're
totally back in love peralta i need to
ask you something let me guess will i be
the best man at a last-minute vow
renewal ceremony that will serve as an
emotional capper to this magical weekend
no i need you to move the car kevin has
decided to leave immediately kevin
kosner leaving the lake house
this was 100
all jake
oh terry
oh sir that's a dribble cup you're
dripping on yourself am i okay look i'm
really sorry
no need to apologize your death doppel
tylogen scheme worked you manufactured a
perfect romantic moment and i allowed
myself to imagine as kevin held my hand
that he still felt something for me when
we came back i walked him to his room
and just as i was working up the courage
to ask him to stay
he said
we shouldn't spend any more time
together
well at least now i know that my
marriage is over
so
uh thank you peralta
raymond holt
leaving the living room
then he called her cheryl not doctor
cheryl a clear attempt to delegitimize
her obviously i agree she has zero
legitimacy i mean she calls us a doctor
cheryl then kevin brings up how
cheddar's french comprehension has
regressed chatter's tutor says it's
because we're not speaking enough at
home the worst part is we used to share
socks with an odd number that was a
tense negotiation enough all you do is
talk about kevin this needs to stop i'm
sorry i wish i could stop thinking about
him but he was my husband for 20 years
if you know how i could just erase him
from my memory i'd love to hear it
we could get really drunk
yes let's try that how are you feeling
not good at all useful to watch out for
me diaz the good news is the heavy
drinking worked you didn't mention kevin
one time no that is an accomplishment
unfortunately
it appears that i did think about him at
least once last night what do you mean
at 3 30 a.m i seem to have sent kevin
a digital phallus portrait my digital
phallus portrait what is that
oh no you sent him a pic
what did you just do i texted him a
picture of my penis like you suggested
no oh
i meant for you to call him and tell him
you've been thinking about him why
didn't you say that i thought it was
understood hold on he's writing back
well what do you say it's a lengthograph
it's a scatter plot with a
very robust data set well that escalated
quickly sir i didn't realize you were
still staying at roses i thought couples
counseling was going well not anymore at
kevin's request i offered to reduce my
work hours by 26 kevin countered with 50
which i counted with 30 then kevin says
40. seems like a lot of math for therapy
that's what dr cheryl said anyway kevin
refuses to budge from 36
and i'm starting to worry that i might
lose to him you mean lose him no lose to
him therapy is a chess match and
i will prevail
hey what's going on i'm helping holt
pick a dating site oh this looks good
phds only uh actually in this context
phd stands for pretty huge oh my
i can only assume that md's only stands
for medium rosa can i talk to you for a
second sir if you want to get a date off
of these sites you're gonna have to give
me a little more from your profile photo
i just gave you a series of eight poses
each increasing in sexual
provocativeness by one eighth if you
wanted sceptiles or deciles of sexiness
you should have told me uh
what why do you care so much santiago i
thought you didn't like the idea of me
dating yes initially but then i thought
about your metaphor about how
relationships are like a chess match and
it really convinced me that was a strong
observation so why don't you think of
this profile photo as an epic chess move
like vladimirov's thunderbolt of 1987.
close the door diaz i'm removing my
collar stays this app's pretty simple if
you don't like the guy's profile you
click dang and if you do you click dang
that sounds needlessly confusing why
dang is bad and dang is good okay let's
thin this herd untucked shirt no thank
you born in san diego yikes an adult
named todd so this is what online dating
is like
i didn't realize realize how good you
have it with kevin no how it hasn't
changed you still have to pick someone
based on looks and hope for a connection
later oh lord help me i'm going for it
i'm clicking dang no dang is bad click
dang why is this so confusing how do i
get hot todd back oh no rosa they're
leaving together what are we gonna do we
stop them even if it means we have to
kill todd smart let's go
looking for someone sir oh what's going
on what's going on is that you were
trying to manipulate me but it is i who
manipulated you how does it feel to
suckle from your own tainted teeth not
as bad as it feels to hear you say
suckle so you were never really going
home with todd didn't actually think i
would have relations with him i really
thought we had something wake up todd
i'm out of your league you thought you
could meddle in my personal life but i
was 10 moves ahead the whole time and
now checkmate oh i love chess have you
seen the queen's gambit it's a tv show
taught us where the guy
we wanted to apologize and if you want
to gloat about how you outsmarted us go
ahead we deserve it i won't be doing any
gloating i mean i did last night i went
home and had a drink to toast to your
humiliation but it didn't feel right
because i had no one to toast with i
want to share my glee i had won but
i was alone
and i realized this is exactly what i'm
doing to kevin trying to win
therapy
and it hit me
i care so much about winning
that i've lost everything
tell kevin how you feel
it's raining you could run to him this
is the real world santiago relationships
end in unsatisfying ways every day
people don't run to each other in the
rain
kevin
raymond
[Music]
raymond am i too late too late
my friend saw your dating profile and
your photo without collar stays
i thought i'd lost him
you will never lose me
i'll do anything to keep you i'll
compromise on everything the work the
[Music]
nancy myers never fails
now that we're doing it it feels kind of
weird to be staring at your friends
while they kiss are you kidding it's
beautiful
[Music]
i love you
i love you
you